lisa is in Ohio I'm Lisa
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
longtime listener first-time caller how
you doing better than I deserve
how you holding up I'm Darrin okay my
problem is I have a millionaire that
refuses to let me have a dryer
he is completely against a dryer I have
no reason ever like like a washer and
dryer
the washer and a dryer yes so you're a
husband you guys aren't you guys are
millionaires well he is a millionaire
I am NOT we are not married when you
look together oh and it's our money
until we get to the checkout line and
then it's not our modern American you
ever really yes okay so he says it's our
money so I buy exactly that's what I
keep telling him it's your money but
I've even offered to buy the dryer I
have I get disability and my home was
paid off by the time I was 30 and then I
didn't drop out of the workforce until I
was 38 I had a surgery and almost lost
my left leg and yeah so I've had a
really okay so you have you personally
have how much money not counting your
roommate I have personally saved roughly
25,000 I have 20 of that locked and a CD
that will come up next year at 2.5% and
watch this how much is a dryer know I've
even offered to pay it no no I wasn't I
said how much is the dryer I don't know
how much a dryer would be five six
hundred more than that depending on the
shop for one and eight okay well I mean
maybe maybe you ought to determine what
the price of the drivers you haven't you
have a washer right mm-hmm okay I mean a
washer
he reached
and I have a dryer down there and the
dryer like I was offered to have
somebody come out look at it oh it you
there's one sitting down there that
doesn't work exactly okay so I'm
confused why can you not just go buy a
dryer he does not want to owns the house
that you live in he does okay so he owns
the dryer that's sitting down there yes
and how long have you been living there
eight years okay
I think it has never worked yeah I think
you I think there's a lot of other
things aren't working this dryer is just
part of it so you are you are you are a
case study on why shacking up doesn't
work okay well we both agreed we didn't
want to marry one and the very GetGo one
because well I've been married once and
it just fit and work out for over car
wants how to read too but I think what
driving cars right and then he's never
been married and then I I'm not really
interested in getting remarried anyway
right now and you want a dryer well the
one reason is I have MS so I have a lot
of medical bills that would be better
you know it's unresponsible for my own
you you're an outline case study
everything is coming out of your mouth
is the reason that checking up doesn't
work it's very very difficult to manage
your life this way because you're trying
to act like you're married and you're
not and therefore you don't have a way
to solve a basic disputes who's mustard
is it in the refrigerator it's like when
you're in college and you have a
roommate and somebody buys mustard no
someone else uses it and so it's just
because you're freaking roommates
legally financially and in many cases
emotionally your roommates with benefits
you know that's all
is and so that's what your that's the
core of your problem and so I don't know
I if I were living in someone else's
house can I go buy a dryer and put it in
their house well I guess if you sleep
with him you probably could get by with
that so you know that's my guess
so go buy a dryer girl just have it
delivered just trot your little butt
down to the dryer store buy a drawer
dryer pay the delivery charge have them
come up and put it in the room and have
them haul off the old one that doesn't
work and if he doesn't like that you can
pay him for his old one that doesn't
work and then you have a dryer it's
magical
but you don't really have standing to
cause your roommate to buy you stuff you
just don't you and this is the problem
with this halfway thing of doing it
paint or get off the ladder kind of a
thing and so and I've never I mean I've
been doing this for 30 years and I've
never been able to coach a couple
successfully it's not because I'm
obstinate about it I've just it's just
there's too many things pulling it all
this stuff the wrong direction I've
never been able to coach as a couple how
they can sort of be married and you know
and it just it doesn't work out so I
don't think you have a problem it's it's
none of your business
what he does with his money because he's
your roommate you don't get to go now if
the two of you two are married and
you're married and he has a million
dollars and he brings a million dollars
in the marriage and then he's too cheap
to buy a dryer then you've got a
discussion which it's absurd he can't
buy it right of course he could buy a
dryer normal human beings have a washer
and dryer when they have a million
dollars that's just weird so he's just
being a tightwad beyond belief he's
strange and so that's what we're talking
about here so go buy a dryer girl it's
not up to him if you want dryer go by
your dryer you're free person you if you
have money in the bank and you have an
income coming in from a disability and
you can make it out there in the real
world and you can make a decision you're
38 years old buy a dryer it's not that
big a deal